es war ihr erster termin nach der
winterpause harry und megan am dienstag
zurück in london sechs wochen hatte das
paar in kanada verbracht eine kleine
flucht nach einem schwierigen jahr
kaum 24 stunden später folgt die große
flucht völlig überraschend angekündigt
in einer presseerklärung
wir beabsichtigen von unserer rolle als
hochrangige mitglieder der königlichen
familie zurückzutreten und arbeiten
daran finanziell unabhängig zu werden
während die ihre majestät die königin
weiter voll unterstützen wir planen nun
unsere zeit zwischen dem vereinigten
königreich und nordamerika aufzuteilen
im königshaus gab es seit längerem
diskussion um die rolle des modernen
glamourösen vorzeige basso die
inoffizielle rollen beschreibung bislang
doch die rückzugsentscheidung sei laut
britischen medien gefallen ohne die
queen einzubeziehen
es herrsche enttäuschung der
verletztheit hinter den mauern des
palast verletzt zeigen sich auch harry
und mägen von der art wie die britische
boulevardpresse ihr leben zu zerstören
versuche erklärte mccann im vergangenen
herbst eingezwängt in das hofprotokoll
zu wenig schutz für sohn archie gründe
für einen unklaren teilrückzug der ein
abschied werden könnte harry und macken
können feststellen gerade wegen der
feindlichen art der verkündung dass die
queen charles und william wenig
zugeständnisse machen die familie
betrifft die regeln einer
tausendjährigen institution ändern in
der eine teilzeit eine mitgliedschaft
noch nie funktioniert hat die
verhandlungen über die künftigen
beziehungen zwischen den stars access
und dem rest der königsfamilie laufen
das traumpaar aus prinz und ex hollywood
schauspielerin will nicht mehr richtig
mitspielen ein schock für das royale
britannien